I think I think wait I think I'm waiting
but i think i think it's already gone
through it said it went public all right
ok so we're live we're broadcasting I
you know here we are again I believe
this is our first night chat as ever I
can't Sam so here we are we're talking
at night with producer John Paul rice
he's the producer behind one hour
fantasy girl as well as mother's red
dress we believe he yet he's already
underway on his next project and maybe
we'll hear a little bit about that you
know throughout this conversation and
the magic stone magic stone has kind of
been you know that's in Benin in
production but it's it's you know is my
promise story post-production so John
hears we want to start today's
conversation and thank you for it for
joining us by the way we know that you
put in long day's long hours you know
and this is the time where you have in a
moment to speak you know this is like
your downtime and here you are choosing
speak with us so thank you yeah we
really appreciate that where we want to
start off today was your you're an
original backer of goodbye promise on
Kickstarter you know which means that
you've had access to the film you've
also you came out to see the film at the
downtown independent you know during a
world premiere and then here for any
gogo campaign um not only did you
support this campaign you know support
the film again but you gave more than
the two dollar amount that we're asking
for and we just want to start by asking
you know why did you know since you've
already seen the film and you've already
supported the film why did you elect it
to support that you gogo campaign well I
think having a relationship with you
almost for three years now has been one
of the largest reasons why I did what I
did I mean having seen the film it's not
just the simple matter of supporting it
but what you've done for the community
to support hundreds and thousands of
independent film artists it was the
least I could do as a gesture to give
back to all of what you've done not only
for me personally
and giving me an opportunity to share
some knowledge experiences and also our
work with the film courage monthly
interactive that you guys did on the
downtown independent but more
importantly it was the hardness spirit
behind basically what i believed about
you both his people and what I saw up on
that screen and so for me it was like
yeah why wouldn't I you know why
wouldn't I do that because we all
understand how hard it is to not only
make a film but to believe in what we're
doing and even when we have doubts even
when we have challenges so it was to me
it was something that i just i would i
would do more and i would do again if I
could that's really nice ya know it was
it was you know it's touching you know
and your generosity and we and we thank
you for that John and I ya know it's you
know it you know we found it's
challenging you know over the years you
know because everyone always talks about
like audience building you know and you
sort of you do this thing where you
build this audience and on it it's so
funny I saw like a tweet online
yesterday and it's just like yeah just
go ahead just build an audience of
10,000 people like 10,000 dedicated fans
you know and I'm just thinking like do
these people realize how hard it is just
just to find a hundred dedicated fan you
know let alone 10,000 it's just like
where do you get 30 people to watch your
YouTube video account minutes yeah huh
you know so yeah you know so for for you
to continue to to sort of come along you
know the the reciprocal relationship
that we have about supporting one
another's work just means a lot you know
um yeah yeah so um did you have any
other questions you want to jump in with
so far for general uh well let's see
when you when you attended the screening
um how did you feel we did with making
it an event
you know we tried our best to sort of
emulate what you know John recent sherry
can talk about insurance was to like
rather divided making an event and you
know it's tough when it it's about
actors and you know we didn't really
have acting teachers come but we had a
Johnny roast-beef who's been in the
industry for years and is very
passionate and soulful we wanted to have
him come out and and and open the crowd
and then we had kevin gant of the Jeep
last Kevin I'm who has his own goodbye
promise story and and so we try to keep
that theme and keep a lot of heart
behind it so just just your thoughts on
on the premiere and how he thought we
get a baby ways we can improve um you
know I thought it was heartfelt I mean
if you know when people talk about
marketing and events I I can say that
I've seen a change in myself over the
over the years it's not about wowing
your audience is really about feeling
into your audience and so everything
that you guys did to me reflected the
values of the film and I think that's
what's most important because
authenticity is is really what sustains
substance that people remember I mean
that song reflecting his own story in
his own internal I mean if i were to
criticize something about it the only
thing I would have done was I would have
had a mic on and made him a little bit
louder you know because I was sitting
like halfway up and you know we were all
listening very intently and it was a
well-composed song and I think that
opening it up with that speech you know
very passionate guy who believes in in
you and the movie and has his own story
of how he you know struggled I think you
know it it fit with the overall tone and
theme of the night and I think that's
that's where it comes from the people
that you know like attracts like so you
drew you drew in people that reflect
with the values of the movie and the
people who made it and I think that you
know if you can feel good about that and
your success that I should measure it
you know we thank you John and with that
I like I like to talk a little bit about
mothers red dress because because you
have a story here similar to goodbye
promise where you had shot the movie and
then you turn the Kickstarter ended up
raising $20,000 for post-production
funds and so you know here you are you
know you're able to do that you know
that creates sort of new opportunities
um you know like you know you don't have
set to do things the set way that anyone
else does it because you know you've had
you know you're able to crowdfund that
money so it gives you a little bit more
freedom in terms of what you're going to
do next and so can you talk about maybe
um as you finish mother's red dress
what's your what your strategy was in
terms of you know getting it out to the
world that having people see it well I
think when we made mother's red dress we
thought it was going to be a certain
type of film and then when we got to the
editing and got to the ending of it we
found the ending which took someone's to
do we had we have shot a sermon ending
and we kept with it ending we actually
didn't do any kind of pickups there's a
story behind this but essentially it
took us six months to find what the true
ending of this film was and what I
realized what it was was a very personal
film it was actually probably less
commercially viable than even when our
fantasy girl in some respects in terms
of it had a more palatable appearance
but the message of the film was going to
hit home with a lot of people and it was
going to fall down on one side or the
other in terms of like this movie
totally resonate and I don't want it you
know I don't want to deal with this I
and and so when I came through
Kickstarter I think the the difficult
challenge was the subject matter in the
way that we presented it but I wasn't
trying to wow an audience of people into
getting excited about subject matter
other than going this is who we are this
is what it's about and if you like these
kinds of movies that speak to you then I
think you know would be great to have
you on board and get involved and the
people that put the money in and their
time in promoting it on Facebook and
Twitter and among the people that we
didn't even know was very inspiring
because they felt that the movie
reflected something inside of them
something that they felt would be
important to them and so how I
approached everything I I don't really I
don't want to say I don't have a
strategy for it because that's not true
I mean I did think about all the
different avenues in ways that we could
get the word out about the movie but
after the film is now out I've decided
that the best route for us to go is to
build a library of movies and bundle
those together and sell once we get
monster killer down our next film seldom
as a three pack as opposed to one offs
and there's a number of reasons why I'm
doing that but i wanted to do you know
dynamo and amazon and a couple of other
traditional platforms but not really to
go and just give the movie out there
because again it's a very personal film
and so I've learned on every movie that
I've done every film that I distributed
today um we start out with an idea and
it evolves over time hmm so does that
mean that you know in terms of film
festivals because I know it's gotten
into at least the Derby City Film Fest I
believe it's called I guess it you did
you
did you submit to a lot of film
festivals and then back off that or mean
what was them it was that part of that
initial strategy and then you back off
it or what had happened there what what
happened was we got invited to submit to
about 20 different festivals some of
which were I you know I would say that
her upper tier if you want to call it
and I had reached out to the festival
directors and sent them you know some
press kits and literature on the films
and trailers and I think we're came down
and some of the responses was uh was
very intense for them that ultimately
what I realized about the festival route
for our type of our movie mother's right
address was that it could be played in a
festival and we earned some very good
relationships out of it with some
prestigious festivals but ultimately due
to the world's economy and especially
the economy in the United States and
some of the smaller festivals it was not
an easy sell for them um and I you know
I knew Chris Chris had known me
Christopher Rommel from the Derby City
Film Festival he had brought one our
fantasy girl to Louisville to two years
earlier he felt the film headed you know
great merit and he said you know I know
you're great it for promoting you're
gonna do the best job you can to get on
TV which we did and the paper and you
know I know you have reasonable
expectations but i understand that
festivals are up against the wall right
now they're really trying to bring in a
lot of stuff that that could be seen by
it wide of an audience as possible as
easiest type of material for people to
see and it's a very difficult time so I
mean I was discouraged a little bit by
not getting into other festivals but at
the same time you know that didn't
determine the success of this movie and
how I felt about it or how other people
have felt about it John I'm wondering
why you choose to go with some of the
more
heavy hitters in terms of story that you
do I enjoyed both films but I know there
are people that might be scared by some
of the subject matter whether it relates
to close to their own situation or they
don't want to face anything that's might
be slightly dark so what is it about
going there that attracts you because
you know that some of that subject
matter is not going to be commercially
viable and it is going to scare give you
programmers away a little bit but then
you stick to it and you're attracted to
it well I think in the same way that
most filmmakers approach the films that
they wanted the stories that they want
to tell you know mother's right dress
was a film that I wanted to do and it
was the interest in the material the
excitement about it the same with one
our fantasy girl and the same with
monster killer um I mean it to say it's
dark I I kind of have an opinion about
this and I will be a little bit candid
about it to me a dark movie is one that
lies to you I mean to me a dark movie is
a movie that tells you something that is
false that that is I mean is it's like
cotton candy you know it has a flavor
for a second and it dissipates and it's
gone and it's it's like an empty Hamburg
to me uh you know my editor Brian Nelson
actually said something to me because I
try to categorize these movies and he
said you know the kind of people that'll
want to see your movie are the ones who
go that was a good movie and he said the
reason why it was a good movies because
it meant something and for me I want to
I want to portray the truth and to get
as close as I can to the truth but yet
at the same time evolved not just to hit
people over the head for the sensation
of it or you know none of our reviews
have come down the line where people
feel that we're exploiting subject
matter or people and the stories or
ideas but um really more or less to to
tell something that I feel is true and
Edgar feels is true as well and that's
that's kind of where we
down on that and you know if if it if it
rings true with people that's great if
it doesn't you know that's that's any
film that any filmmaker that's ever made
a movie will tell you that all you can
do is just make it and what people think
of it is this tote entirely out of your
control you know and so in the end I
mean you're saying that in overall you
should have made a strategic decision
that you're going to give the film up on
I mean you know that you're going to
kind of hold off because you're going to
get one more in sort of bundle three
films at the same time as far as we know
that the film is available on Amazon it
so it's also available and dynamo why
did you choose those two platforms and
did you consider any other methods at
this time or is that really like you
just want to have him on those two
platforms and that's it for now um I
really didn't have the time to focus on
getting out to other platforms I mean I
could've there's a couple of other
avenues that could have taken but for
the time being I learned a lot from one
our fantasy girl and iTunes is great for
us and it's a great you know but it took
so much time for us to get past the
threshold of paying back the Apple fee
the initial fee that they charge you so
basically you're spending you know six
months to a year promoting a movie that
you're not going to see a dime on on
iTunes unless it's a big hit and then
you know a lot of people come in one of
the things that turn that around for us
and I think it's a very it's worth
exploring through a cost effective
measure is getting an app free app for
your film um I do think that that had a
big deal of significance in us getting a
lot of downloads of the movie and a lot
of streams and I think that for me right
now the best the best thing that I can
do is to put it on amazon and dynamo
because most people are streaming or
downloading nowadays I really didn't
feel that retail DVD was
going to I mean even if we got a deal
for that was even going to be profitable
for us because DVD sales are such and
decline the only DVDs nowadays are
family movies kids movies that sell and
as far as cable goes I mean we would
have to we're trying to recoup on
investment and get a little bit of money
back into the company or at least the
way mother's red dress is structured I
can I can take money from that movie
that is portion it to my investment in
it and actually put it into the company
and put it into other movies so you know
for us it was an overall strategy that
right now we wanted to put it on
platforms that we can control and we
wouldn't have to give any rights away to
do that and if we needed to pull it from
those platforms we could do so fairly
quickly John how many views does the
official trailer for Mother's red dress
have well the teaser trailer has over
550,000 on YouTube um and I have to tell
you I I marketed the heck out of it the
day that we launched it um I mean it was
all over Twitter and all over Facebook
probably the first week I mean in terms
of within the network if you will people
um I think that Google or well I should
say Google because of the song married
to it took that and I think they have a
very I haven't researched it but I think
I have a pretty complex algorithm that
paired it up with about three or four
other trailers that were you know in the
same kind of ballpark of range there
were a few that had some stars in them
that were coming out within the next six
months and that probably accounted for
over 150,000 views not initially but
over the course of like six seven months
and then it just continued to take off
from there raised song in the end the
teaser has been a big success and but um
but then we got other ones our second
our first official trailer has over
18,000 and then the other one's sense of
our in the you know couple to several
thousands
do tell i mean what were some of the
specifics that you did i know you work
very hard i think you mentioned one time
that you had sent so many direct
messages that twitter cut you off until
it go earth at what 200 is the limit to
Reno's come on it's your quickie but but
what you okay so what what were some of
the specifics because I mean so many
people can tweet something and it
doesn't take off like that so obviously
you had a lot of great people behind you
and also a lot of your hard work I think
I think for us it was um you know people
who had seen one of our fantasy Gerard
least notice from that this was the next
you know this was the second or the
sophomore film released and so there was
an anticipation to it I also think that
the song there were a lot of reactions
to the song honey bee that people were
really most interested in and hour at
least even if they didn't you know I
want to say care about the movie but you
know the images or whatnot the song kind
of carried him through that and they
really felt it was a fitting match the
tone of the images of what they saw so I
think that that was a that was a big
play and i didn't i didn't know that
song was going to be such a hit and ray
you know become a big I don't say it was
just because of that but Ray was doing a
lot of things on tour internationally at
the time and that and that trailer
really helped drive a lot of traffic to
his website and get his skin his work
out there which I was really happy
because I wanted to promote him I felt
that he was really talented guy um you
know I think I asked my caps to my crew
to share it with everybody um you know
wasn't just on social media I think that
we got embedded on some really good
sites and then some other people picked
it up as an indirect result of our
efforts and and that that just overall
helped it you know I know and speaking
of driving traffic I mean over half a
million views I mean have you seen an
impact from the amount of views the
trailers have gotten to amazon to die
and what it has it reflected in sales at
all right it has
has increased them but I think that you
know the mobile views are actually
increasing more and on mobile devices
you don't have all the links that you do
on your you know home pc or your mat so
you don't get the description with with
the hyperlinks that you can actually
click on on your mobile device at least
on an iphone that I know um so if the
the views on dynamo and I can't really
account for the views on amazon but i do
know that on amazon there's been an
increase over though every time we have
like a new review that comes out we see
a spot I don't know if that's directly
you know I can't measure the metrics and
I really don't want to spend a heck of a
lot of trying time excuse me time you
know trying to figure out where it came
from here and tracking it you know but I
do see an increase and I see a lot of
people actually telling each other about
this film and we're actually in the
middle of launching a new strategy for
the movie altogether too I wanna say to
be branded or remarket it's not going
it's still going to be mothers red dress
but it's it's going to be directly
marketed to people that know this this
matt this subject matter and know that
the type of thing that we're saying with
this movie there that are totally in
line with with the message of the film
did you reach out to you know abuse
organizations I know with with one our
fantasy girl I think you had also
reached out two dissimilar you know
maybe women that were recovering or
whatever um similar yeah it's it's very
difficult I actually started this back
at the Kickstarter campaign last year
the problem is is because of all the
budget cuts state wine a lot of social
services and organizations have very
little money i mean few if you have some
you know wealthy donors here and there
that can contribute but we're talking
about
were they hundreds of you know tens of
thousands of dollars each month to keep
some of their programs going a
partnership like ours is very small at
this time for them and so they're
looking for bigger and more commercial
ways to you know get celebrities
involved with their organization
possibly even partnering up with
national organizations you know also and
I kind of give a little bit of credit to
this in in the response I mean we've
gone to national organizations and some
of them have said it's almost I don't
want to say too powerful because it's
not the exact words that they used but
they they in light of Penn State and a
couple of other abuse cases they're
really trying to focus on the victims
and they really don't want a story about
parents and I'll leave it at that
because I think that it just when you're
trying to get a child out of a bad
situation and you have to confront the
mother and father in this case you're
also trying to get them to come on board
so that they can give that child
counseling and help and in many cases
social services and the court system is
not able to intervene and just
necessarily rescue that kid out of a
situation so i looked at the overall
thing and I realized what I was going to
go do is I'm going after the people who
follow the teachings of Alice Miller and
she's got a whole history of books
online about parenting and abuse and it
and those people have responded
overwhelmingly to the movie they just
feel it's very powerful in fact some of
them say it's not even harsh enough for
them but I'm really encouraged by that
community and so I've been targeting
that community as opposed to the
organization's did she write the drama
of the gifted child
yes yeah she's written like excuse me
she's written over a half a dozen books
she died a couple years ago but her
website and community you know all the
people that still carry on i guess the
torch of her message but drama to get
the child is probably the most
well-known of her books you know Donald
curious with you sort of like you know
backing off you know promoting marketing
selling mother's red dress um you know
how are you then able to get this next
project off the ground no because I
would love to go to say that I ok I'm
just gonna hold off I'll pushing this
one I'm going to go ahead and just make
another feeling how are you able to do
it John well I you know I think that I
realized that it each movie is its own
unique and individual piece and so your
fan base is not necessarily going to
follow you to the next film I mean it if
you make the same type of movie you know
or style of movie that everybody sees
you know of course you're going to have
some people obviously that liked one
over the other I've had people like both
have had some people loved one hate the
other um I think you all tamiya mother's
red dress one our fantasy role mothers
red dress and monster killer is that you
have to love your work first because if
you don't do that if you don't enjoy
what you're doing um you're doing it for
empty reasons and and so I was able to
go you know what all the I don't want to
say the hype but all the excitement that
I got into the first one and was based
and predicated partially on maybe what
if it could possibly and not looking at
the reality of going you were doing each
of these movies to get it better and
each one is practice
and it's not to say that it means it's
less of a film this way but use this as
your time to learn as much as you can
because if you want to go up and budget
and go up in names and go up in the
scope of your story um those problems
are not solved by money those are solved
by your creativity your experience your
knowledge and know-how what to do with
that so that when you get there you have
you know an opportunity to actually
perform well and execute so for for us
it was you know mother's red dress could
you know we're going to see how it
releases as it is with the marketing
that we set out with and in that process
as we are kindly actually how we did
with one our fantasy girl we learned who
our audience was we learned on that you
know there are going to be people that
like it there's going to be some people
are afraid to see it um you know I'm not
going to try to go out there and counter
all those perceptions one because they
don't have the money to do it and a to I
don't have the time so I need to go to
the people who may not be on social
media who may not be on facebook to take
a look at this movie and you know fan
base is important facebook fan page and
twitter and all that thing's great you
know communication is wonderful but
ultimately it's like the people who
showed up at your premiere it's the
people who gave to your kicks or your
Kickstarter campaign and gave to your
IndieGoGo campaign those are the things
that matter what if you had a million or
not doesn't matter and if other people
say that that is what is important then
they have no business telling you or
anybody else what to do because all of
us it's not about just a struggle but
all of us play a role in what we do and
we're only set by our own limitations
basically you know you are you can be
your own worst enemy and for me
I wasn't going to let you know basically
a movie kind of going this direction
stop me from making the next one and in
between having a full-time job and you
know making these films I had to be
proud about my work and what I was doing
and so um I needed to move forward but
mother's dress dress does have a market
it's just that it's not the market that
we thought but there's a new way to do
it and it's new to the people that we're
reaching out to as far as the online
community and blogs and the scent the
other you know I can't worry about what
they're doing they got their own things
there you know writing about this and
I'll continue to reach out to them but
if they need to be new and fresh and you
know something that just came out and
well I I can't I can't satisfy them but
I'm really probably not trying to
satisfy those people well John I
remember I think was the first time you
were on our radio show you had this
great line you call them red carpet
producers and I think I've given you
credit a few times because I really love
that the you know the term but in
keeping with that how do you know that
you're continuing on for the right
reasons is there a self-test you know is
there an unofficial set of questions you
ask yourself or others are they
continuing on for the right reason or is
it for the wow factor or is it to
stylist by their own creativity um well
I think for me I can say that I've had
doubts about not like serious doubts
like am I in the right business am i but
I've had doubts about myself I've had
doubts about my abilities I've had
doubts about the film's you know through
different times but all of it is up here
I mean the reality is that you know when
you do work there was can I also just
stay this there was a man that I met
earlier this year I was on my way to
louisville kentucky and i stopped at
o'hare airport five thirty in the
morning an 83 year old white-haired man
was sitting outside of a restaurant
waiting for it to open
struck up a conversation with him and we
ended up having breakfast together he
said to me in the course of the
conversation my first job was 10 years
old I was making seventeen dollars a
week cleaning pig pens and he said you
know you want to know what my last job
was I said yes he says I was the CFO of
a 500 million dollar company and I
retired at 60 and he said what I learned
from my first job and the man the German
man that I worked for and the four other
boys that were with me is a man told me
always do everything that you can do the
best your abilities every day doesn't
have to be perfect it doesn't have to be
amazing it's just do what satisfies you
he says I wasn't even good at math but I
liked working for this guy and I liked
making money for this company that's
those are the things i enjoy and he said
i have no tolerance for people that
never did any work so I'd fire him ah
and that in that trip I think it humbled
me a little bit afterwards to realize
that that is exactly what you do you do
everything you can to the best of your
ability and you can't you know of course
you're going to go through doubts and
you're going to have disappointments
life is going to be that way sometimes
you're going to work with people you
don't like and you're going to make
mistakes too the key is do you keep
moving forward or not do you keep one
foot in front of the other and I think
that's a question that you have to
answer for yourself for a producer you
know you can play all sorts of cards and
games really what it comes down to at
the end of the day is you have to live
with yourself as a person and what you
do both in your personal and your
professional life and so for me I can
answer that question and i can say that
i'm i'm pretty happy with that i love
the story i always loved these these
these so then indigo thank you for share
that one
John you know in terms of moving forward
in terms of you know overcoming that
self-doubt and moving on to the next
thing when you take a look at what we
did with our goodbyes promise release on
IndieGoGo can you give us some feedback
you know how would you evaluate it in
terms of you know just are there how
would you evaluate that I guess we'll go
from there Oh from the goodbye promise
campaign on IndieGoGo I think you guys
did incredibly well because if you look
at it you had 400 plus people contribute
do you want to call them by your movie
or a renter film um and you made before
fees and taxes you may have over thirty
two hundred dollars i would say in 30
days that's pretty awesome for any
independent filmmaker to bring home a
check like that within a couple of weeks
after releasing it I don't think there's
many indie filmmakers myself included
you have made that same amount of money
as you have in one month and I think
that's pretty awesome and I think that
you know the numbers if you just want to
look at numbers alone for four hundred
people anywhere to do anything for
unknown talent putting themselves out
there on one in a web page I know you
have other outlets but just one sort of
vehicle for your distribution and to do
that within a month it's pretty awesome
and so I think you guys did exactly you
did a major success story I mean to me
you know people can look at that that
bar what you achieved from you know cure
to hear of you know article was a
million obvious I know was it but if
they're only measuring it that way you
know it's like they're not worth your
time to be critical of you but I'm
saying it's it's honestly thirty two
hundred bucks and 30 days it's over 100
bucks a day and rentals or downloads or
strings or whatever that's pretty
awesome and then even if those are
people that have previously backed your
film or I'm sure there are a lot of
people that have discovered it I've seen
some of the tweets have seen something
reduced people have written you know
that's that's got to be a great feeling
and encouraging yeah I would definitely
a soul yeah that's really cool what
suggestions would you make to improve on
it um well I I don't know you know in
terms of improving on it I think that
what you guys did you were the first to
do something so of course you know both
novel and bold and you know the same
time is open to a lot of improvement um
but I you know I don't really have any
specific ideas just to try to tell you
all here's what I would have done
differently I think that what you guys
put together was an effective campaign
that reflected the spirit of the movie
which was to get everybody you know the
way you edited the pitch video on the
trailer I thought that was you know very
effective I think that your sincerity
came through not only in the video but
also hey look we're just trying to you
know recover some costs on the film you
know that we poured our heart and our
soul into I think that's a very I don't
think many films can do that I don't
think many films can pitch it that way
and and and for people to understand
that and feel that I think that in terms
of the story I don't think it's limited
to the industry and there's this sort of
a paradox there because a lot of times
people in the industry tend not to care
about somebody else's work or the
filmmakers where they go a good job you
know they don't rent it or they'll buy
it that sort of thing um I think that
your audience is actually people who
have been considering before giving up
on their dreams and I think it appeals
to a much broader base than just the
actor or somebody in the industry um the
the other thing I mean outside of the
the gogo campaign I would strongly
recommend you David use this as a
calling card for what you're capable of
doing as a director with I mean it's
improvisation which is that alone you
guys strung store
the casting and the editing and the
directing I mean it's it's all there and
I would really use it as a launching
point to get other actors on board
whatever next project that you're going
to do with a good script because you
have you have a couple of years to be
able to sort of leverage that I mean you
always have the footage of course but I
would really use this as a vehicle for
you to go up to the next level um in
terms of distribution I think online is
probably the best route to go for this
movie because once you get into
television broadcasts you're going to
you're going to have to spend some extra
money to get things up to broadcast
quality and that's just that's anybody's
moving that's not just yours that's
anybody's to you know color correction
all the deliverables all the sound you
know they're gonna want certain things I
don't know if you guys are thinking
about that but um I think what you did
was really smart and I think you made it
easy and very simple for people to go
here here and watch and i think that the
easier that we get to that type of
method where people don't have to click
here and enter this gear and go here and
you know okay now refresh your browser
but actually just be able to go and
click and pay that's why amazon is one
of the most successful online places to
go buy stuff because you can just do it
so quickly it stores everything in a
wallet and i think that as time goes on
you know film is going to benefit from
that as well and and with a new
contributed to that he go go yourself
did you actually go through the prime me
now after contributing did you go and
watch the film yes I did I watched it
probably about a day or two later and I
you know I went back and looked at
certain parts of it that i remembered
that i liked more you know like some of
my favorite moments in the movie very
cool not it on and what do you think
John in terms of you know as we move
forward I mean some news I don't know if
you saw that broke today is that vimeo
has added a tip jar where um you know
and i wish they would have done this
with the free
but I guess they introduced it with the
with the paying account so if you have
if you have a pro account or a plus
account you now can add the feature of a
tip jar to your videos we're at you know
it's just one way for creators to sort
of monetize their content so that was
something that we saw those announced
today but what do you think about what
what we're able to do with it you know
with with goodbye prompts need to go go
big picture for all content creators all
filmmakers moving forward I think I
think it's just another I think what you
guys did just makes people think in more
critical ways instead of sort of
hammering you know waiting for the next
I think I think what happened and I
relate this to someone of my journey
over the last four or five years as I
think a lot of times your social media
we get psyched up about all the new
distributions coming it's coming it's
coming Tom's here you know this that the
other and we we obsess over that but
rather than use our own creativity and
go out and create something our own
momentum the things that we're capable
of doing ourselves and we're only bound
by the limitations that we put on
ourselves to do that I think what it
does is it shows people look you know
you can either wait for these other
people to give you your chance or you
can go and create it yourself and what
you guys did was you took a crowdfunding
platform that most people used to raise
funds to start a movie or finish a movie
or do a cause and you said we're going
to distribute I mean it add that to me
is genius because it just took a little
bit of thought and going maybe it'll
work maybe the womb but we're going to
try and I think the more people do that
you know the more people going to learn
and that just helps everybody I think
overall feel that they have a chance and
a realistic one if they put forth the
effort okay no I love those words you
know I love then that was really you
know that that was a big part of the
spirit buying the whole thing was just
literally like looking at the platforms
that existed like you said not not
waiting for that next
they come along because we keep hearing
that it's always going to be that next
thing coming along and and you know cara
de i always joke when we attended um you
know we attended this like two day
filmmaking seminar and and you know and
there was like this older guy there and
this was several years ago is just like
and he's like he's like I really want to
shoot my movie on on the red scarlet you
know like I'm waiting to describe it and
every one of the rooms like bro like
don't don't wait for the scarlet just
get whatever camera you can just make
your movies like I was like you know
we're going to shoot on the red scarlet
it's just like and I remember can I look
at each other like a year or two later
thinking like wait a minute did the red
scar never come out it's like right as a
cook you know at that point at that
point I was like it's like come on yet
or whatever it's just like what is this
guy doing like you know just just you
know so yeah but that was a big part of
it was just like but yeah you know we
really think on our side that you know
the transparency that you see on
crowdfunding platforms we need to see a
lot more two more that because they
bring out this social emotional
component that doesn't really exist on
you know on platforms you know currently
you know you don't necessarily get back
component from amazon you don't get it
from diamond that you don't get it from
a lot of these places there's just
something about the transparency about
the numbers about the ticking clock
there's all these things that factor in
that really draw you in there they're
really engaging and and we really like
to see distribution up distribution
platforms open up on that you know
really open up on that so um yeah we
think that's where things are going yeah
and it's great too because if you think
about it like Vimeo ok so what a regular
count is what 60 like for the non free
account and maybe that the premium is
200 something so if you have that tip
jar they're great then you have to
actually make that worth your while to
sign up for those premium services in
order to get that back and the same
thing with getting on iTunes you said
you had to wait what a year for one hour
fantasy girl dash six months to a year
yeah okay right all right so that's
that's beauty of doing it with with
IndieGoGo the way we did was that if
nothing happened well we were not really
anything except David's time to edit the
video
and us to shoot it so you know that's
that's the thing I mean you you think
that that different platforms are going
to all this will be great and all that
I'll take you up and but you still have
to recoup some of the initial cost put
in so well it's there's nothing I think
to further your point about that and I
think you know most of us who made a few
films now get it is that there's no
platform that you can be on that's going
to save your film or making your money
back you know it comes down to do you
have something to say that resonates
with people and if it doesn't well that
doesn't make you any less of a person or
less of an artist you just go back to
the drawing board and try to do
something else i mean the the worst
thing you could ever do is to give up
and quit that's really what it is is
giving up as quit you know you know a
failure is quit and so you know i look
at the things that I've learned in the
process and I go joy really you know
measure my success Sully you need a stop
yeah okay what happened hold on you guys
okay yeah
ah
are we going back down are you guys all
right yeah what happened Oh Karen still
looking at it we um I guess we got we
might have to end the broadcast there
it's not looking good out there we had a
some guy ash some some guys here crashed
into the stop sign right out here oh
jeez yeah oh man thanks are they okay I
mean are they is it just like a fender
bender or you know they throw everything
everyone's okay there's no one there's
no definitely don't hurt but it's this
man's it's going down a tenth yeah that
means this yea though I yeah well thank
you for your time John we're gonna
really let you you know uh no warnings
and I guess you know come to an end here
this is exciting finish the bang yeah so
we're gonna sort of tend to tend to this
outside so I completely understand yeah
but not sure if we'll leave this it or
not thank you for everyone for tuning in
oh yeah we got to deal with you know
it's like a big RV crashing into a stop
sign right in front of our no right near
our property and that whole thing so
okay all right man well I hope
everything works out okay and and have a
good night we'll talk soon thank you
John all right